what's up guys this is the full podcast
between myself and Navy SEAL Jeff gum
I'm hosting tons of calls just like
these in my Discord so I definitely
recommend joining up there's going to be
a lot of really cool stuff and you guys
get to ask questions to these crazy
people yourself there's no visuals for
this podcast so I would recommend you
throw it on while you do some chores
around your house or you just want
something to listen to while you're on a
walk uh we got into a lot of really cool
stuff we told some amazing Stories so if
money was a Navy SEAL so I've talked
about his psychedelic experiences how to
conquer your mind a lot of really cool
stuff so hope you guys enjoy it yo yo yo
all right I think we can just get
started people will keep coming in as we
get going awesome all right how you been
Jeff we haven't talked in a while yeah
yeah been really good down down in Miami
cranking on a bunch of different
businesses and everything was traveling
uh
last
traveling a lot this summer I was in Key
West last saving sea turtles working
with scientists and other special
operators and then I was in a Columbia I
was in Mykonos bouncing all around so
lots very busy summer that's kick ass
um you want to give like a quick intro
about yourself so you know where you
went to school how long you were a
sealed and whatnot
definitely definitely so I grew up in
Pennsylvania in the Lehigh Valley
Poconos area I lived there until I was
18 and then I wanted to go away for
school and my cousins had gone to UCF
and they were successful entrepreneurs
they lived in Orlando and so I came down
visited um uh checked out UCF loved it
and just started just started I was an
Army ROTC studying business
I went to Airborne School summer after
my freshman year and all my best friends
there had just graduated SEAL training
so I so I I realized I've been in better
with the seal Community
um
after after graduating majoring in
business management entrepreneurship I
went out to California did SEAL training
I went to Seal Team five was two years
of training four years at Team five then
I ran all the combatives and prisoner
handling for four years instructing guys
going through training and also more
advanced seals and operators as well
kind of trained to train her so they
could go and train the guys in their
platoon and then uh I was really close
with the Gracie family that created
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu and UFC I went down
to Brazil with them several times I saw
everybody wearing this type of swimwear
down there called sungas and I bought a
bunch of them all over everybody loved
them I was like oh I got a gotta share
this life hack with the rest of the US
and created single life then started
making bikinis and board shorts and
silkies and
um I did that for a year while still in
the Navy and then I traveled around the
world with my friend who was born
without arms and legs went literally all
the way around the world like one and a
half times uh
had a lot of really cool Adventures went
to 20 plus countries Dove the Great
Barrier Reef climbed the highest
mountain in Australia went to you know
Israel to Mykonos to
Croatia sailed sailed yacht week it was
a lot of crazy awesome times and then
got my applications in for my MBA
started at UCLA brought single life
through the entrepreneurship pipeline at
UCLA Anderson and kind of built my team
with other MBA students and it was my
Master's thesis there then I graduated I
moved to
uh Miami a little bit before I graduated
since everything was remote at that
point and Florida was way more free and
and open and so uh California was super
locked down with masks and craziness so
uh went out to Florida it was uh yeah
best best thing I did there and now I've
been just keep having more and more
opportunities have several new things in
the pipeline and uh founded several
companies the last year year and a half
since I've been out here and then do a
lot of work
with veteran foundations uh saving the
coral reef helping train amputee and
spinal cord injury veterans and then
bringing them on surf and ski trips with
the Adaptive training Foundation I'm on
the board there and then do a lot of
Epic charity events like swimming the
Hudson River with 200 seals and Patriots
and swim for soft and San Diego
finishing at the USS Midway and uh all
kinds of Epic challenges like that so it
keeps me busy and keeps me having a lot
of meaning in my life at the same time
it's a really cool fun way to continue
to serve yeah that's killer that's
that's a that's so awesome that you
continue to do that
um I know you've you've done a lot of
college throughout your life
um like how how important has College
been in your journey and um like
translating over to business would you
say your time being a Navy SEAL and like
going through that struggle was way more
important or like you really did learn a
lot at college and you're definitely
glad that you went for all those years
you know there's there's several parts
of college that that make it a good
investment part of it is the things you
learn my undergrad was honestly less
about what I learned because I was just
100 focused on being a Navy SEAL getting
that degree I think it's important too A
lot of times when when you attempt
something that you uh that that you
finish it same with whether it's SEAL
training College MBA I'm like I already
started this I'm gonna see it through I
start this business I'm gonna persevere
through the times that are tough for me
but um the network from college was
incredible I was in a fraternity and
from that I have like 10 plus lawyer
friends who I can reach out to for
anything I have a lot of my best friends
who from that from that fraternity and
from UCF and a lot of guys on the
football team that I'm really close with
that are very successful now it's a big
reason why I moved back to Florida and
but then you know kind of very similar
type of thing in the SEAL Teams a lot of
very hyper focused successful people
that that don't give up and it's like a
Brotherhood to a whole nother level and
then going through that struggle with
them and it's not just going through the
struggle and Seal training but you know
going through going to war going through
all the training you do before you
deploy and then going through sniper
School
and breacher school and all these other
challenging things non-stop them
becoming an instructor having to go
speak to lots of students teach
different classes and it really
translates well into you know pitches
that you do as a as a business owner or
being able to communicate
whether it's sales or just talking with
potential clients
and then another getting my application
into UCLA Anderson and doing the
entrepreneurship pipeline what was
probably even more beneficial for me
than doing grad school was doing all
these accelerators where I was meeting
with very successful
entrepreneurs people that ran VC funds
and private Equity Funds within the
billions of dollars and get it like
hearing their stories them listening to
mine and just having to communicate what
I what I did and what I built with my
own company over and over and over made
it much more polished and uh so I think
they're I think they're all important uh
nice so mainly like networking though
for for the importance of college that's
what you say was the best thing
totally yeah because a lot of the guys
here are are in you know a very unique
position where you know they're they're
trying to go that entrepreneurial maybe
content creator out and you know
everyone's forced into going to college
essentially out of high school but what
I like to suggest is you know you say
network is really big but I I didn't
make any of my networks from um from
going to college or anything like that I
got it from you know starting businesses
going to events you know meeting as many
people as I could I mean I met you at a
at a charity event
um yeah Tick-Tock marketing for your
clothing yeah back when I was still
running my my Tick Tock marketing agency
I know so it is it is really interesting
like you going to college if you utilize
it correctly can get you a ton of
connections but I definitely think that
people need to recognize going out and
doing [ __ ] on your own and just figuring
it all out can also make you just as
many or you know sometimes even more
connections because I like to say that I
have a pretty cool um list of people on
my contacts
and and college is kind of a way to
de-risk where if you just go out and you
try to like make a company right away
um and that doesn't succeed then you
know you learn you learn a bit and
everything but it can be it's kind of a
way to de-risk as well like once you had
a really successful company then you
then you ended up kind of dropping out
of school and stuff because you were
pretty set and and everything but a lot
of times it can be
that's that's not necessarily the norm
so you can go you can go to college you
can work on a side hustle at the same
time and then uh you can it's really
more beneficial when you can take what
you're building and apply it to that
business do accelerators do and then you
get all these other if you're in the
right schools
um like especially UCLA Anderson is a
lot of the smartest business people who
a lot have a lot of experience same type
of thing a reason I kind of learned
about the MBA and that route is because
I had several friends in Los Angeles who
did their MBA at Wharton upenns business
school and they all they all played
rugby there and they were just doing
huge deals Non-Stop and founding
companies there are business partners
with Floyd Mayweather founded Mayweather
boxing and fitness founded xpt with
Laird Hamilton
founding all these uh car auction
companies and private Equity companies
and they were doing it with all the guys
they went to school with and I was like
wow that has a lot of uh you know
benefits going there I had a you know
swimwear and athleisure Company at the
time so I didn't see as much value to
going to like School in Philly or Boston
or or San Francisco I was like there's
more value to going to school in Los
Angeles and a lot of unique
opportunities came from that I got to go
on Mike Tyson's podcast I got to meet a
lot more you know influencers and people
I would work out with Jake Paul and Nick
Diaz lived with me at one point and had
all kinds of famous people wearing my
swimwear and athleisure which would
mostly only happen in Los Angeles and uh
and then kind of the same thing going on
now in Miami a big reason why I like it
here it's kind of taken the finance from
New York it's taken to Tech from San
Francisco
taken the entertainment
influencers and celebrities from LA and
they've all come to Miami now and then
Miami also has the cryptos and nft and
beaches and boats and wants Caribbean
water yeah so lots of lots of girls for
sure so uh yeah that's good way better
taxes and everything at the same time
compared to these other states yeah
Miami's a spot I'm excited to get down
there by the end of the year
um what would you say are some of your
biggest tips for for like networking so
when you're in those areas like LA and
you're meeting all these crazy people
um like how do you get into contact with
all of them is it because you're a Navy
SEAL and potentially you have more
connections or what what advice would
you give to you know more regular people
to do awesome networking like that
you know I'm I'm a pretty extroverted
person and because like most Navy Seals
don't
aren't as extroverted and might might
not say yes to as many opportunities and
and I like would say yes to all these
opportunities and it would
I would go to a lot of events and that's
where I would meet a lot of people and
then I would just be authentic and
genuine and I'd meet someone establish a
like a real connection kind of just like
me and you did when we were in and uh
and I didn't even know you were doing
all all this stuff we talked hung out a
while exchanged numbers had a real
genuine authentic connection nobody was
trying to you know
do anything weird and then then we just
started like trying to be like oh I got
this so you I do some Tick Tock stuff
and just like trying to provide value
the same way you kind of offered to me
oh I could help you with some Tick Tock
stuff and and then uh
I'm like I'm like man amazing and and
then not being afraid to ask for help
either that's another thing A lot of
people are afraid to ask for help once
you have that connection and I had a lot
of mentors and friends and business
friends who who are like very
specialized in certain certain areas and
if I'm like all right I'm doing this I
need to do an SBA loan I get some money
to kind of grow my company faster and
scale and my friend had done a bunch of
them he worked in finance
um for doing tech tech private equity
for many years so then he really helped
me with my the whole SBA SBA thing and
then so not not being afraid to reach
out to to friends like that and just
establish people know when you're being
being fake or not and and you know you
can ask for stuff but also try to
provide value a lot at the same time
that same friend who I I like you know
asked for help with the SBA thing I had
taken him shooting and trained trained
them in a in a bunch of like tactical
shooting like Navy Navy SEAL style so
you know kind of kind of provides value
to people and and not be afraid to ask
you know at the at the same time either
because people want to people want to
help a lot it's a great way to pass it
on whether it's
kids reach out to me on Instagram and
different things asking for advice on
SEAL training or whatever and and I you
know pass pass on the knowledge I had
because a lot of people helped me along
the way and I wouldn't have been
successful without it yeah that's
definitely a big tip that I have for
networking is trying to show that you
can provide value as early on especially
before you start like asking for
anything in return
um so many people like the within their
first messages they're they're already
like giving signs and they're trying to
show what they they can get out of you
if you just show people that you can
provide value and you give more of an
authentic and genuine interaction it
results in like a much better like
overall just a much better relationship
and you you know you do bigger things
together rather than if you're just
trying to cut corners and just get
little things from people you know what
I mean
yeah I couldn't agree more and then
also if you have some things on the side
where you are
the same way you were trying to you know
create create a financial literacy
program for for inner city kids and
stuff and the way I am with uh
supporting homeless veterans and amputee
veterans and and ocean conservation when
people see you doing stuff like that I
think they're even more
um and that's not why I do it at all but
it's just something I I kind of start
thinking of right now I'm like you know
people that
they're even more likely to help you
when they see you doing more work
that's you know helping helping others
yeah exactly
um some people in the chat are asking if
you know who who uh and your Tate is I'm
assuming you've heard of him at this
point right
yes yeah I know I know who he is what
are your thoughts on on that guy and you
know everything that he's been saying
and getting canceled and whatnot
yeah I
I like I like a lot of this stuff I like
a lot of stuff he says there's really
like a war on masculinity and and you
can see it it happening
um it's it's much easier to kind of be a
victim than it is to be like a Victor or
a hero and and ever since Society
started rewarding people literally
having competitions on who can be weaker
who can be the most uh
um who can be who can be the biggest
victim basically who can who can you
know I check as many boxes when it comes
to Identity politics
um instead of just being people going
and trying to be be the strongest be you
know helpful be you know it's it's
really crazy I just saw this one video
today and it was like a a spoof on the
Titanic and it was like oh if 20 if if
the Titanic sunk in 2022 it'd be like
men and men and uh Children First the
women women
like have equality and so they can they
can wait and that's not really you know
the way the way it should be
um I think you know masculinity is a
gift just like femininity and
and uh I completely agree it's so
fascinating how they're trying to go
completely backwards with what has been
the norm for so long they want guys to
be so in touch with their feelings and
and that's all you care about and if you
call someone the wrong pronoun how that
makes you feel like anything you say you
have to take into account the other
person's feelings and it's ultimately
just breeding so much weaker and more
depressed people like there's no wonder
depression rates are up so much when all
everyone thinks about is how they feel
and if you don't feel happy at one point
like there's something wrong like no
like it's okay to not feel happy and
there's usually a reason you don't feel
happy like maybe you're not happy you're
not content with the situation you're in
but instead of using that and going and
taking a pill and smoking weed all day
you can try to use that as motivation to
start a business go to the gym work
harder but they just don't want you
thinking like that at all anymore it's
pretty amazing to see and it's it's
pretty clear of the agenda that they're
trying to push onto people nowadays it's
wild
yeah exactly it honestly is started with
China and Russia there's videos dating
back nearly 100 years with their
strategy to try to do that and
demasculate men and everything else and
at the same time they're doing that they
uh obesity has skyrocketed people are
just on their screens all day
people aren't eating eating healthy
people are just binging TV shows all the
time and if you're
people would feel a thousand times
better and
if they would just work out get a sauna
get sunlight eat healthy eat eat some
healthy grass-fed meat uh
yeah I can't agree more with all that
yeah 100
um how how important do you think it is
for people to and endure uh struggle
throughout their lives like as we just
said you know Society breeds people that
only care about their feelings and
you've gone through more struggle than
anybody else in this call you know I
just love to you for to hear your um
your thoughts on how people should go
through struggle to ultimately expand as
a person
no it's the greatest it's the absolute
greatest teacher that there is to go
through to go through struggle I went
through through it as a very little boy
when my father died and then kids would
pick on me and I would fight them and
then you know clearly through Seal Seal
training and everything I had a lot of
struggles there and I learned so much
about at the time I I hated it because I
got sick and had to start all the way
over and got sick and had to start all
the way over my blood had become toxic
with muscle waste I had Rhabdomyolysis I
had viral gastroenteritis it had rhabdo
had never been diagnosed at the time
because everybody would quit when they
got it because they would become so weak
it would affect them so much physically
that they would quit mentally and uh I
knew who I was on the inside being being
a pretty good athlete training very hard
for this preparing
SEAL training is still hard but I
wouldn't have been challenged to my core
the same way
at the time I even felt a little sorry
for myself I'm not gonna lie it sucked
to start all the way over I'm like damn
it why did this why did this happen to
me but then once I
made it through and founded my own
companies and was in business school and
studying for tests it's what I think
back to all these struggles I had before
having to go through you know hell week
twice having to go through like Bud's
first phase three times and that's just
to be able to make it through selection
and have you know you still have a year
and a half left when you get to that
point and it doesn't get easier it just
gets more technical
and and so going through all that was
what I thought was like like sucked
ended up being the greatest gift that
ever happened to me and I'm and I'm so
I'm so glad it did and so now every time
something really tough and challenging
um like happens to me I say good like
I'm Gonna Learn I'm gonna be stronger
there's gonna be a lesson in this and uh
it all goes back to the hero's journey
as well every kind of religion Greek
mythology
um
the Vikings everything I mean all the
movies from Star Wars to Spider-Man to
Superman they have this hero who goes
through something challenging he's
almost defeated but he perseveres rises
again comes back stronger than ever and
he's like a new like resurrection of him
of himself or the Phoenix
yeah and and it ends up being and it's
what it's
I mean it's what makes a good story it
what it's what makes the lesson and then
it's what a kind of a lot of masculinity
is about at the same time persevering
being being that provider being being
the strong being the strong one to uh
not not give up and it's a it's a
beautiful thing
wow so when you had that that crazy
blood disorder and you know you were
pushing through it like where my mind
goes is in the future if I'm
experiencing like insane pain I would be
nervous that it's some crazy disease
like that but I don't know what's going
on how do you kind of conquer that in
your mind to to you know not think about
if it's like a super bad medical thing
going on that you have to worry about
compared to something that you should
just push through
yeah this is another thing I've I've
spoken about know when it's time to
persevere and know when it's time to
Pivot so through this this time you know
we're getting I got doctors checking me
out I'm with you know a lot of
I'm I'm 20 I was 23 at the time I was
really strong I was healthy I persevered
I just smashed myself through until I
made it
um
go by several more years a few
deployments hurting my back in the
Middle East
having a spine surgery having an ankle
surgery having a shoulder surgery
training with a bunch of guys in the UFC
and injuring my back more and more
and kind of realizing uh I should
I should find a new goal being a seal
was awesome for 10 years but I'm only
getting older and I can use it as a
foundation to to uh
make something else that's that's great
and and successful so I pivoted into
business but still having a way through
these veteran foundations to continue to
serve and so all right I've I've
accomplished nearly everything I want to
accomplish as a seal and now my body I
my body is actually messed up and I can
make it worse if I keep trying to smash
my way through as
as you know a more like being a lot
older and having having a lot more wear
and tear on my body compared to when I
was younger and I could I could just
smash through but mentally uh when it
comes to businesses and everything like
that you can
you can just like push through for the
most part yeah 100 with business it's
it's it's different I mean it's a very
unique question because there's not many
people who are going through such
physical hardship as a Navy SEAL to
where you have to like actually be able
to differentiate where you should keep
pushing and then where you should change
course what was it was it really weird
coming back to the to the real world
like the The Matrix after um after being
a Navy SEAL
like having a trend like just switch
back and like your mind is still in like
I don't know if it's combat mode or
what's the the best way to phrase that
but like what was the transition like
back into regular life
you know some people struggle with it a
lot more
um I honestly I feel like I had a pretty
good transition and part of that could
be because I had such a big goal for
business and everything else I also
didn't come back from deployment and go
because it does take a little bit of
time to come back from Iraq or whatever
and and
uh go right back into society I mean I
basically came back from Iraq and went
to a sniper school then breacher school
and I was still then I went did a
mission where I was working with the
Secret Service like protecting Obama in
Hawaii and all kinds of things and I was
back with my whole uh platoon training
for the next deployment I never almost
got a break there but
when I came back my second time then I
became an instructor and it was almost
like like a halfway civilian job I'm
still in the Navy I'm still
um a seal but now I'm based in San Diego
I had a first a like a condo downtown
then I had a like a townhouse in Pacific
Beach and
and it was a little easier to you know
be it's not like I went right into uh
a normal job or something so I was I was
training the guys I was still you know
in the community a hundred percent but I
wasn't I wasn't deploying or going to
war and then you know a few I became the
lead petty officer then I founded my own
company then
I started I did a program that helps
seals transition to the private sector
it's called the honor foundation and
then we went to
Silicon Valley uh toured all the like
Airbnb Google Facebook LinkedIn all
these tech companies and I was like I
need to make my company right now
because I was originally thought I would
make it after business school or
something and I was like nope I need to
make it right now and then um
so so I so I did that and then I got out
so I felt like I had an easier
transition some people were a lot more
stressed than me I had a plan to go
travel the world for a year and a half
while using the travel to Market my
company and apply to business school if
you are getting out of the SEAL Teams
and you gotta provide for a family and
all these things right off the bat and
you don't know the type of job you you
want or you have passion for I imagine
it would be a lot tougher as well a lot
of guys were more scared about getting
out and transitioning than they were
about going to war and that wasn't that
wasn't the case for me I had a whole
crazy itinerary planned of places I was
going to be going
that's crazy you said guys were more
worried about transitioning back into
the regular life then then literally
going they were they seriously were and
and uh when I did the instructor
qualification course where we have to
get up and give a lot of speeches and
talks and different things one of the
guys he started talking and he's like oh
man he goes I am so nervous I am I get
less of I get less afraid when I'm like
trading trading bullets with the Taliban
or Al-Qaeda and
and I was just like what because that
wasn't my case I'd get up and talk and
mostly have fun
um but everybody everybody can you know
is is different like that and
and uh yeah that's fascinating
what I'm gonna start bringing some
people up to
um
lift it I just invited you to speak if
you guys have any questions just raise
your hands and I'll bring you up what
were some some points when you were um a
seal and in like a crazy situation where
um I don't know like the distress ever
almost get to you when you were in like
a combat situation or something like
that or they trained you well enough to
where you were always pretty prepared
because some of the stuff you guys deal
with is like it's quite literally like
mind-boggling so I couldn't imagine
actually being in the moment dealing
with that stuff
yeah I always I actually always wondered
myself what it would be like when I was
doing my first mission and everything
I'm like am I going to be scared or or
what and
literally yeah I just ran I I wasn't I
mean I trained for so long it was like
being a football player doing a lot of
practice and then finally you're in the
game finally you're in the Super Bowl
finally you're getting to do what you've
been
training for for so long
um it's the SEAL Teams are very
different from a lot of the military and
that it's like two years to be a seal
then you go to your team then it's
another year and a half training with
your team until you're going to go on
deployment and fight because you have so
many things you got it you gotta get to
such a high level I'd say like Army and
Marines you can go to boot camp at like
17 or 18 boot camps like three months
you can go to your unit maybe train with
them for a couple months and you can be
18 and a half going to war with like
five months of training if that and I
got a lot of respect for these guys
going and doing that uh
but yeah for me for me I was just
excited when I finally got to do it wow
that's crazy
um Lyft you have a question you want to
ask Jeff
I was asking about Legends what serious
thoughts about Legends
yeah
oh religions
um
so I had a really
I I was always kind of unsure and stuff
and I didn't I didn't want religion for
me to be like a pro football team it's
like a lot of people they they choose
their pro football team based on where
where they're like what their parents
what their parents choose and where they
grew up like if you if you grew up in
Dallas Texas and your parents like the
Cowboys you're probably gonna like the
Cowboys I didn't want to just you know
go in and follow something just because
my my family did I also gotten very into
Evolution and learning things learning
things like that so
I was like oh I'm not sure if that would
be the way I would choose it if if uh if
there if there is a God and stuff but
then I did some psychedelic Journeys and
I went to
Costa Rican rainforest and I did
Ayahuasca this may sound a little crazy
if you guys that's crazy I didn't think
I didn't think you would have done
psychedelics that's wild oh yeah so I
went and did Ayahuasca and the Costa
Rican jungle and
and I was able to like see
my father my little brother my
stepfather family who had passed away
descendants all this like Divine wisdom
came to me holy [ __ ] and it was
unbelievable and so many things and
trials and traumas that I held like deep
deep down like came out and I was taught
like the lesson from each one of these
things and I did this for three nights
in a row and it was with a bunch of
other veterans and they actually
are creating a documentary from it and I
also had University of Georgia PhD
researchers doing research on us the
whole time and uh
what it did to our brain and releasing
trauma and and these other things and
basically it kind of almost connected me
to these whether they're Dimensions or
or what they are but it was the most
beautiful feelings and and love and
gratitude I've ever felt in my life and
for sure I believe in
in a in an afterlife and God and I I
can't totally understand it but uh
whatever it is it sure is beautiful
that's amazing do you sometimes when
you're extremely stressed do you like
look back to that moment where you where
you felt extreme gratitude and you're
learning a bunch of lessons and it kind
of like grounds you again
yeah it's uh it it does something too
where it gives you allows you to go to
parts of your brain that might be a
little more repressed memories of me and
my little brother memories of me and my
my dad who my dad passed away when I was
eight and I'll just have like tears of
joy just pouring down my eyes and I had
never like felt that before had that
happen before or I would just have like
tears of joy streaming from my eyes and
just feeling all the love and gratitude
and and these beautiful memories that I
have and not before I would think to
like my brother and dad and just be sad
because I miss them so much and love
them so much and they're not here but
just be so happy for the moments I had
with them when
when they were alive and that I'm gonna
see them again
damn that's incredible
yeah psychedelics are insane ayahuasca's
more it's like a more intense spiritual
version of just like regular mushrooms
right
with a lot more
kind of wisdom and and
it's like mushrooms times a hundred but
like beautiful lessons at the same time
and so they're
they're kind of a chemical cousin and
but uh the Ayahuasca is
dimethyltryptamine it's a form of DMT
and you drink you drink it
and uh it's probably the longest lasting
of the dmts
wow that's crazy it allows you to really
process these things whereas there's
other dmts that you smoke that might
last about 20 minutes and I did them too
and they're a lot more intense for the
moment but you you don't get to process
things quite the same way because you
have so much time to sit there and also
there's these healers says this is why I
kind of really know this stuff is real
and Powerful at the same time these
these uh
they're like their nade they're natives
from the shabato tribe in Peru and the
interesting thing is they're actually
Christian at the same time so they have
these powers and he drink the Ayahuasca
and they you know believe in Jesus and
God and and everything at the at the
same at the same time and
and they uh
but they would come and sing and first
the wife would sing and you you know
you've drank the Ayahuasca like 30
minutes before they go by and sing to
every person
but they have a way of pulling this
thing out of you
pulling these feelings and
visions and connecting you
to kind of the Gods in the other
dimensions and when she would do that is
when I would Purge I would throw I would
throw up and then
when the when her husband would come
around who is the more powerful one who
had spent like years in the
um
in the in the jungle living on basically
just plants and he would come by and
sing and then that's when I would have
kind of these crazy visions and wisdom
and and all these things and I'm like
this is a very real and powerful and it
also another thing on religion is
as I was thinking of that I used to I
used to think that all the religions you
know how there's a thousand different
religions and are from all over the
world and it's people's I'm like I used
to think humans are just creative and
they come up with these different
religions based around their culture and
and everything else and then
I was like there's a thousand different
religions and then
as I was kind of have it going through
all these different things processing it
all I kind of realized there's really
one religion there's just a thousand
different names for them because most of
them have a lot of the same
type of
lessons and beliefs
and and then humans do apply their
culture to to that from their areas at
the same time
wow that's crazy
um infinite do you have a do you have a
question you'd like to ask too
uh yes I do actually
um
people have been complaining about the
younger Generations as far back as
Socrates days and I know they're they're
due to the luck of the draw you when
you're in a leadership position you're
gonna get a [ __ ] hit or two a a
shitheater too my question uh question
to you is George R.R Martin wrote when
the soldier lacks discipline default
lies with their Commander my question to
you in terms of leadership there's a
difference between having a team that's
50 effective versus a team that's 90
effective uh do you believe uh what's
your thoughts on
um managing uh uh the youth today do you
think it's
um the younger generation is just
getting softer or do you think that the
older generation is in practicing what
Jayco Wilkin will in willing willings
calls extreme ownership yeah I was gonna
say what what you mentioned first is
very similar to what Jocko says with
extreme extreme ownership and taking
responsibility and it starts with you I
was actually just on a FaceTime with
Jocko uh probably three days ago right
when I was finishing a workout him and a
buddy called me from the Abu Dhabi
combat club uh
championships in in uh Las Vegas I used
to train up Jaco a lot he used to choke
me a lot but uh he actually ran all the
training for when I was getting ready
for Iraq he was a commanding officer of
straight up uh so I think I think it's a
little bit of both and I think part of
it
can be can partly be parents at the same
time that's where it kind of started I
think a lot of
parents
would kind of you know just give screens
and give TV you know they used to call
TVs the idiot the idiot box
because you know they'd say that's what
the idiots do they just watch TV all the
time
um not saying if you watch TV you're an
idiot but there can be a
you know if you if that's all you're
doing it's not the best and and then
unlike all the other Generations where
people were were tan and they ate pretty
pretty healthy there was no such thing
as organic everything was pretty much
organic you know I was raised I was
raised on a dairy farm I ate I drank raw
milk I had you know
really fresh meat and everything and I
think that's why I almost never get I
almost never get sick and my parents
instilled I had chores non-stop from the
time I was like four years old I was
walking the dogs I was mowing the lawn I
was helping my dad milk the cows I was
throwing hay bales around and it
instilled a lot of hard work and I think
that's a big reason why I don't quit and
also my parents put me in all the sports
right away I went from soccer to
basketball to baseball to I started
lifting weights in like fourth or fifth
grade
and at the YMCA and then playing
basketball there and swim lessons and
everything else and a lot of kids are
playing video games non Non-Stop and
when you're just in I think when you're
just in front of a screen it is not not
the best thing for you not saying if you
play video games it's you know you're
bad or whatever but uh that I I think it
all it all adds up
um so I I think it's a little bit this
this generation can can have some
problems some of that can come from the
leadership a lot of the leadership a lot
of the parents at the at the same time
now saying that this is the most
technologically savvy generation of all
time like
people consume more information in like
an hour than it would consume in like a
year 100 years ago and and so
it has its positives it just like
anything there's there's trade-offs you
can have its positives and you there's
also
all kinds of amazing ways to work out
people are you know people that are fit
and strong and work hard and there's
there's more tools more ways to make
technology work for you uh you know a
generation ago it would be harder to
found a company build a company from the
ground up Sunny was 18 years old and he
built a multi-million dollar company
with his with his phone and a computer
so
um you know there's it's it's both if
you if you take advantage You Can Be You
Can Be Your Own Boss and never have a
boss in your whole entire life and that
never could have happened
um you know kids were not kids weren't
really doing that at 18 19 years old
50 50 60 years ago
so
yeah you like that answer yeah no that
was a great that was a great answer and
to go to your point of how I didn't even
really think of that how people are
consuming more information now in an
hour than they literally would in like a
decade yeah 100 years ago it is it is a
crazy thought I mean you're scrolling on
Tick Tock people's attention spans are
like seven seconds so you're you're
watching hundreds of videos within an
hour and it's it's all just like flying
right over your head and on top of that
you're not even giving yourself the
chance to have an original thought
anymore
um people wonder why they're losing
their creativity and they're upset or
why they why they only have their good
ideas when they're in the shower or
they're they're laying in bed at night
and then it's because it's the only time
you give yourself the chance to actually
think you know you're you're surrounding
yourself with content consuming it so
much that you're not even allowing
yourself to have an original thought
anymore it's crazy
yeah I couldn't I couldn't agree more
with that that's another reason I almost
like psychedelics because of the it's
almost like a hack into when you have it
in when you take them you need to have
an intention at the same time and it's
almost like a hack into into figuring
out whatever whatever it is you're
you're trying to figure out there yeah
it's wild I have some experience with
psychedelics
um the last time I did them was one of
the last times I was hanging out with my
friends before moving out of Boston so I
grew up in Boston over the last 19 years
and my closest friends are the ones that
I've basically grown up with since I was
a baby so having that experience with my
friends on the back deck it felt like
one of the like one of the most unique
like nights of my life because we were
able to recall on so much of you know
the journeys we've been on through our
friendships and and uh just how far
we've come over the last like 20 years
and it was crazy like after they after
they left my house that night I remember
just like texting him I was like I love
you all so much and I've never felt like
such extreme um gratitude like you
explained um when you had that
experience so
it really hit with me too like I had
such a similar thing with my friends
it's it's a beautiful thing it really is
there's been some studies with Johns
Hopkins and people who were actually
dying of cancer who who took like a
significant amount of mushrooms they it
helped them cope cope with it like they
were almost 80 percent better
knowing they were gonna die die from
cancer and it's it's really funny I'm
thinking about
because if you have something you want
to be focused on in that you can't think
it's almost like an art if you're
thinking of one thing and you're
thinking too hard then it's not going to
allow the creativity to be there but if
you aren't thinking of it enough the
thought your thoughts will like scatter
and you almost gotta like lasso lasso it
and pull it back but allow it to be
there and like
like bounce around in your mind and then
you can start to have the memories and
everything come from it it's really such
a hack for that
yeah it's it's insane
um
there's some there's some other guys in
here you guys want to also ask some
questions or add add-on
um I I kind of wanted to ask if nobody
else has a question
um I'm just at the park with my dog
right now if you can hear it but um
a lot of people have uh problems with
quitting addictions and vices or habits
and like as an example like I was in
high school and I Vaped for two or three
years on the highest nicotine amounts
and I quit over a year ago so I have
some experience of like how to quit
certain vices but there's probably a lot
of people that are porn at addicts here
or they're video game addicts or
uh whatever the whatever their habits or
addictions are
what do you think those people should do
not in terms of oh well you have to want
to do it but like I guess like how do
you find that reason like what what
should
like how do you get someone not
motivated but get them like kind of like
seeing through the way us X addicts of
whatever it is we are see it
yeah I would just try to go up to the 50
000 square foot View and be like where
where does doing this get me you know
vaping it could be really bad for your
lungs it could lead to you getting
cancer down the road or something like
that think of all the pain it would
cause not only you take away potential
goals maybe you know be tough on your
family and everything else and when you
have your why the how is easy you know
it's like why do I need to quit this all
right I need to quit it so I can or why
if you're somebody who's overweight
maybe they have a food problem all right
why do I need to focus on the gym and
focus on eating healthy maybe I'm 40
years old overweight and I have three
beautiful children and I want to walk
them down the aisle one day and and uh
if I I might if
diabetic or whatever it was like my
cousin was kind of like this and I would
tell him I'm like Casey it's not a
matter of if it's a matter of when and I
want you to be able to walk your
daughter down the aisle I want you to
you know have not only a longer life but
a more high quality life and all of a
sudden it clicked with him and he was
hired a trainer and
started working out almost every every
day and eating healthy he would eat like
half the amount he lost 100 pounds
gained a lot of muscle and changed his
whole changed his whole life and now his
kids are way healthier as well because
they emulate their father and uh so I
would go to like the big the big view go
50 000 feet up in the air look down and
be like why why bind your why and then
you're gonna be able to figure out the
how
that goes the same thing with business
too that's the same exact device I give
people for their for whatever business
goals they have I say like what do you
want to do do you do you want to make a
bunch of money whatever it is um if you
want to be a content creator so you
write down that goal and then every day
you just you just take steps towards you
know achieving that goal you journal and
you you create a plan that's that's like
a perfect example yeah I love I love
that sunny and you can write down
several different things that are part
of that strategy maybe the first one is
just if let's say it's losing the weight
maybe it's working out the in the
beginning because like
giving up the food would be a little
tough when you're when you're working
out that much then all of a sudden you
get you're not sore anymore you're
losing weight from working out you're
like all right time to put fuel on the
fire now I'm going to
um start eating less and eating
healthier all right now I'm gonna mix in
like a day of fasting here and there now
I'm gonna mix in doing a sauna now I'm
going to mix in two a day so I'm going
to swim in the morning or run in the
morning and and work out in the evening
and then you can be like boom boom boom
and keep adding these things the next
thing you're gonna have a crazy
transformation
exactly even at the start of my whole
business journey I remember making like
some of my my daily goals more of just
like I would buy an online course or
something and I was like all right take
notes on three sections and that would
be like like all I had to do on that um
on that list and now
um like two years later I'm at the point
where I I'm able to like fill my day
with stuff and I can get nearly all of
it done all the time so just you know
taking even if it's smaller steps it's
better than um than going then doing
nothing you know because it ultimately
just snowballs and gets you closer to
where you want to be
yeah and probably find an accountability
partner at the same time whether it's a
workout buddy or or a business partner
or somebody else that wants to quit
vaping whether it's a girlfriend or best
friend or a parent or and you hold each
other accountable with that 100 and I've
noticed too when you write it down on
paper and you read it like it'll it'll
literally ruin your sleep at night if
you don't get that thing done so maybe
you know that first day you write it
down and you know if you're trying to
lose weight you say go on a walk and you
don't do it you'll you'll feel like [ __ ]
that first night and the day after you
know you should remember how it feels
when you don't do that that one goal
that you want to get done and then
ultimately you'll start doing it that
will become easier and like you said
you'll just keep adding stuff on that
will get you closer to that goal
yeah I had white boards all in my living
room and stuff it was like a little home
office for me and I would just I would
just write stuff on there like all kinds
of lists all kinds of things I had to do
all my goals make sure check them off
when you do it and and yeah I do it in
my phone too but you think that is based
on habit or motivation
which writing writing the stuff down it
wasn't enough
checking the board as a habit and then
seeing
what you're being motivated for uh so I
so I write everything up there to keep
it cognizant in my mind because you know
we're busy you got calls you got other
things and it slips your mind oh I gotta
go you know meet this person for dinner
but if you're like oh I see that there
and it like refocuses you you like
that's what I'd be like keep that in
mind keep and then it's somewhere that
you see a lot and it's just like front
and center sometimes I'll even like I'll
have it in my phone and I'll screenshot
it and put it in my favorites you know
and I'm going through my photos and I
see it I'm like oh I gotta stay stay
focused there as you know
yeah
um I just uh I just wanted to um say to
to ask what you guys are saying when it
comes to motivation
um I know like a lot of these like Guru
motivation is terrible but there are
going to be days where you know you just
it's just that day where you're like
[ __ ] I can't get anything done and one
thing I heard Jordan Peterson say when
because like he's a really smart
psychologist
uh one thing I heard him say was that
yeah one thing he said was that um
motivation is created by action right
and that's so it's like there's these
three things where motivation creates
action which creates results which
creates more motivation which creates
more action which creates more results
now people think it starts with
motivation but it actually starts at
action so that's why he always says make
your bed because if you make your bed in
the morning [ __ ] I'm motivated to
eat healthy this morning or go for a run
and it it starts small and it kind of
snowballs into doing more and more and
more so that's why I think that if you
guys are ever having that day where
you're like
[ __ ] I don't feel like running today
running that five miles or whatever go
for a walk for a mile and then after a
mile you'll probably realize [ __ ] I do
want to go for a run it just took a
little bit to get the gears going
yep sometimes you just gotta start I've
never I've never uh finished in a gym
and been like damn I wish I didn't do
that you know I I'm always like damn it
why didn't I I got busy and I didn't I
didn't make it or whatever I'm like all
right I'm gonna do 100 push-ups 100
squats and hold some planks and and uh
that I really like what Jordan Peterson
said there and then Jocko also says
um you got to be disciplined not
motivated because the motivation will
come and go but the discipline it
doesn't care if you're motivated or not
you just got to do it like when I was in
Iraq and I had to go do a mission it
didn't matter if I was motivated or not
I had to go I had to go do it you don't
get a choice so it was the discipline
that did that and when I was sick when I
had rhabdo when I was I wasn't motivated
I was I was like dying but I was
disciplined because when you have your
why it doesn't matter what the how is
you're gonna freaking do it
that's the truth blessed you've been up
here for a while do you want to ask a
question too
I think your Mike's you're muted someone
asked what's your bench Jeff
what's my bench I think the most I've
done is like 285 more recently I think I
did 270. I I used to powerlift actually
in high school the bench wasn't my best
I was more of a squat and deadlift I did
a 500 squat in competition and I was
running close to a five minute mile
around the same time and then I had like
a maybe a 480 deadlift I had 505 all the
way up I just didn't lock it out and it
freaking slipped out of my hands but uh
I was better at like
Squat and deadlift I still have the
records at my high school
hmm damn I didn't even know that I know
you did a lot of martial arts and stuff
throughout College
um I don't want to keep you on too much
longer because we already been here for
like an hour but um how did that change
your perspective on everything when you
were doing martial arts in college
because I know there's a lot of
[ __ ] in in college and whatnot and
even though I'm not like an um a person
who starts fights or you interrogate uh
not interrogates instigates or anything
like that at all when I'm at the bar and
stuff there's still some times where
some drunk idiot just comes over and you
know is you can obviously tell he's
looking to start something so when
you're in college and you have that
experience where you know you can just
like literally kick anybody's ass how
does that you know what is that like
being in college with a bunch of other
idiots around you
yeah and I'll tell you I'm you know I'm
38. I went to college when there wasn't
iPhones so you could fight there wasn't
cameras there wasn't anything so you
could people would fight a lot more I I
like never see fights now for the most
part
um and and I pretty much knew everyone
in the in Orlando School in Orlando I
pretty much knew everyone that could
beat me up they all trained at my gym
and they were in UFC uh
you know the people that can beat you up
that that's it I knew pretty much
everyone who could beat me up and they
did on the daily
um
but yeah so
I was a little bit of a Maniac in
college I would never I would never
start fights but if people would come up
talking [ __ ] or a lot of times some
ghetto people would come up I'd be
wearing like an Abercrombie shirt or
something and they'd try to like pick on
me I was kind of I I wasn't as big then
I might have weighed 175 and uh because
I was just training Jiu Jitsu trying to
focus on that and Muay Thai and people
would come up and they'd like get get my
face I'd be like hey man don't get close
to me I don't wanna I don't wanna fight
and then they try to get my face again
and then I would knock them out or choke
them out and and uh
now I've gotten even better at
once I once I signed up to go to Seal
training I'm like all right never never
drinking never drinking and driving
never
um getting in fights I can't risk
getting in trouble this is my biggest
dream ever and that's something I would
talk about
during
um I would I would Mentor guys who are
in Seal training when I was an
instructor and everything we would I'd
lead a mentoring class for like an hour
talk about all these different things
and there are still some times an idiot
would kind of get getting my face or
whatever or be talking to a chick and
they'd come over and try to do whatever
and I'd just like put put him in a
guillotine and choke them out and then
leave them sleeping on the floor but uh
yeah that's hilarious here I'll let um
these last few guys don't don't mess
with people you don't know is is one of
the biggest rules in San Diego too there
was like countless
UFC fighters and black belts and Navy
Seals like it was such a bad place I
don't know how people are so dumb they
just go around getting in fights of
random people at bars that are Navy
Seals and biters like come on yeah you
got to use your head a little bit more
let's see left here lift you have a
question again
I I don't have a question but I just
want to ask him do you know David
Goggins Goggins
yeah I don't know him personally I used
to see him around a lot and he he was
like um
he would travel around being being like
a seal that would go do
uh kind of recruiting and stuff for for
seals and like a I think they called it
like a dive motivator or something
um got a lot of respect for him and he's
raised a lot of money for the Navy SEAL
foundation and challenges himself so I
definitely have a lot of respect for him
and the stuff he does
it's a different different style than
mine I'm definitely a little more chill
but
but uh and more more into martial arts
and all that but got a lot of respect
for him for sure
yeah he's a cool guy I like watching his
videos
son you got to do a reaction video Bud
oh yeah
um Kevin you have a question uh so how
you guys doing today we're doing good
so I had a question and it was basically
like what is the best habits you guys
found
to help you keep your mind sharp but
like other than the normal ones like
working out eating healthy reading is
there any things any ones that aren't
really popular that you guys have used
and it's proven effective in your life
you'll surround yourself with awesome
people that motivate you when you're
doing that and you know they have I
don't know if you know the saying like
you're the you're the average of The
Five People You spend the most time with
um when I was like getting ready to go
do my MBA and I would I would hang out
with all these guys that had their MBA
from Ivy League schools and had had
founded several different companies so
if you if you just like and and seek out
people that give that give you energy at
the same time and and are good people uh
then I I'd say that's almost the best
habit don't put a lot of energy into
people that are
you know kind of blood blood suckers are
negative they're around positive
positive people
all right thank you what else
yeah
um I I didn't know if you wanted me to
add on to that but
um obviously surrounding yourself with
people who are more successful than you
and motivate you is very important I
remember when I was back home this this
last summer I was like smoking weed um
almost every night because all of my
hometown friends would do that that was
just kind of the thing
um and on nights where I wouldn't hang
out with them I kind of noticed that I
would still crave it
um even though like if I if I didn't
hang out with them one night and I
wasn't smoking I would crave it but then
once I moved away and started
surrounding myself with other people
more successful than me who obviously
don't smoke because you know successful
people don't really smoke weed I just
kind of lost that craving completely and
I haven't done any substances at all
since I um I moved out of Boston so
definitely surrounding yourself with
people is like as much as it said it's
it's one of the most underrated things
you can do to to go for a better life
yeah I love totally love that
um and then even grab like just
thinking of all the things you have and
practicing that gratitude at the same
time
um being thankful 100 I think and then
going for more
um who else has questions
um I just wanted to add to that
um about what you guys were saying too
um like I'm the editor for sunny so
we're we're cranking out lots of content
and for the course and also for the uh
for the YouTube channel and I think like
if you're someone like me who really
doesn't have anybody from their Hometown
who's kind of like in the space of
trying to improve themselves do what I
did go online reach out like I met Sonny
not through a bar or some group of
people where we smoke and we know I DM
them showed them what I could do he
recognized talents and we've tripled the
amount of views or doubled the amount of
views we get on the YouTube in a month
or like three weeks so surround yourself
with successful people people who know
what they're talking about and different
things and use each other's talents for
the good
it's a great Point Owen
yeah
love that
yeah building when you have a team and
partners it's a hundred times better
than being a solopreneur I was a
solopreneur for years and it sucks
yeah it does make it a lot harder but
you got to make sure you're surrounding
yourself with people that you truly do
trust and um really solid Partners
that's a big thing for it yup big time
because if they're not a help they're
hindrance exactly
you don't need people holding you down
kebba and fight or Lyft yeah Jeff uh you
say you're Christine what
what's up
okay it's a religion and he says
Christian
um Jeff I mean you I believe you said
you don't like really tie yourself to
one religion you're kind of just more of
a spiritual person correct
yeah I was I was raised Catholic
um I wouldn't say I'm not Catholic or
not Christian but I think there's a lot
of there's definitely a lot of things we
don't know or understand uh
and that's okay
but what do you think like there's like
they they think they believe in the like
day of the end where it all comes down
to like one religion so like
people that are good they just like
you go to heaven and stuff like that
they believe in that
uh I believe there there's definitely an
afterlife I definitely believe in them
for sure kind of seen it
yeah but uh like
okay I'm basically a Muslim so uh for us
it's like there's like an wait let me
translate that okay
so it's a domesday
I guess doomsday yeah I don't really
believe in Doomsday
possible but I don't know
hmm
or can I ask like did you have anything
to say like why don't you believe in it
why don't I believe in it I never I mean
I never saw a doomsday I never
you know well uh did you did you ever
see a god
I would say I saw God I saw
I kind of you know through the Ayahuasca
I kind of saw family members who had
passed and my ancestors and
um
you know had these special feelings at
the same time
yeah no I definitely get what you're
saying and I I think it's he he
obviously has a language barrier so it's
probably hard for him to communicate
exactly what he means and when you grow
up in a religion where you um you know I
don't know too much about his religion
but if everything is like very strictly
to the book
um rather than more interpreting stuff
it's definitely hard to understand
um people who are outside of of that box
you know what I mean
yeah yeah definitely
um yeah ask you one more question yeah
what's up man
so this is for both of you guys
what is like some big
mistakes that you guys wish you could
avoided when you're making when you're
on your journey to where you guys are
now
um I mean I can answer that first real
quick I don't I don't regret any any
mistakes I've made because I've learned
lessons from all of them if I made those
mistakes and continued making them then
I would be more upset with myself but
you know I go into every decision I make
with confidence and if it ends up being
you know the wrong or a bad decision I
learned from it and it you know it just
helps helps me grow in the future so I
don't like to like dwell on stuff in the
past I just like to you know learn from
it and incorporate the good stuff into
the future businesses and you know who
I'm becoming
you know I kind of talked about the uh
persistence versus pivot and
you know I don't I don't quit very easy
and I think there was times
I should have ended a relationship
sooner and probably ended some
friendships sooner
because they weren't
they weren't really good anymore and uh
that's a lesson I would I would go back
and
and so now
sometimes when I see it happening again
I'm a little quicker to uh to to end
things when they're not suiting you
the like being more decisive
yeah not letting not kicking the can
down the road
yeah the deal with it in another day
yeah that's a good point like just
dealing with stuff right up front rather
than just delaying it all
yeah uh I just wanted to say like once
upon a time back when I was in the Army
I did a uh I was a play actor I was a
quote-unquote gorilla Fighter for uh
Green Berets
um uh Robin sage that's their their
their Capstone their their final
training before they actually get the
Green Berets and that was three weeks
out in the field where they came they
actually parachuted in and we were in a
fictional country and all that noise and
just for those three weeks they started
training us on on little Habits Like the
first thing they taught us was how to
quickly change the magazine on the N4
like Smooth even when you're stumbling
it's smooth but just being around those
guys for three weeks
and learning from them and them teaching
us next thing I know I'm this young
private with a whole bunch of of uh
offices around me training them how to
properly handle uh uh an M4 on the Range
that's after three weeks of doing
nothing but muscle memory just because I
was around all those uh Special Forces
types well they weren't quite Special
Forces yet but it might as well be uh
yeah because being surrounded by them
yeah I love that I did some
um
I did some training like that with the
with the Army as well uh when I first
got to my Seal Team it was like a
intelligence Source Handler type thing
and I had to
like basically swim in do all this stuff
uh it's good it's it's really fun
working with some different units and
everything
that's awesome
um oh yeah it because being around it it
was once where we did a mission and this
was cold it was raining it sucked it was
in the middle of the night we were
hungry but everybody was just motivated
because it was just so much fun
yeah such a such a unique part part of
your life and I'm sure you can look back
look back on that uh that was something
too during sometimes even deployed or
you'd be you'd be bored or whatever I'd
be having more meetings with sources or
whatever and I didn't feel like it and
I'm like come on stay focused this is
important work and
um you know you're going to look back on
this forever be be grateful for where
you are right now
um so I don't want to keep you on too
much longer Jeff we've been here for a
while but before we go I'd love to hear
what your um what you're working on
currently and uh you know what future
business ventures that you've been up to
lately
definitely so uh really fun product
worked on for almost a year and you've
you've helped me with this uh it was the
the Frog men and it's the the frogmen
nft if people want to check check it out
it's frogman.io and we're uh basically
hunting board apes and and we have a lot
of the most prolific Navy Seals on on
our team we have Rob O'Neal who shot Bin
Laden in the face three times we have Ed
Byers who's the first SEAL Team Six
Medal of Honor recipient
um
another like 10 10 or so Navy Seals who
were just amazing people and uh created
a lot of really awesome 3D videos uh
hunting the board apes and all this
stuff
um the only downside was as soon as it
was like ready to launch and we had all
53-26 of our frogmen uh the nft market
kind of crashed so we're just holding it
all holding all their assets waiting for
it to come back and then
we're gonna put 10 into veteran
foundations uh supporting all that stuff
as well also launched challenge coin
crypto it's built on ethereum and we've
donated over 50 000 two different
veteran Charities that's it uh
thechallengecoin dot IO just launched a
whole apparel line and everything with
that too
and so that's that's pretty exciting I
also just became a partner in a gun
range that's being built off of 40
minutes west of Palm Beach in
Loxahatchee it's
it's like nine acres
and gonna have like four ranges a kill
house combatives unit all this uh yeah
badass shooting private private members
Club kind of like a country club if you
if you uh if that makes sense it'll be
be called Train club kind of like Fight
Club but Train club and Rob O'Neill's a
partner on an Army Ranger some some
other veterans so that should be a
pretty fun experience uh and and venture
too and then
just a lot of the charity work I do at
the same time
yeah that's really kick ass one of the
things that really differentiates those
products and um projects and stuff is
the team behind it you know
um a lot of the people in this space
aren't as experienced with running real
businesses and a lot of it's more of
just cash grabs so I'm excited for that
for that to launch I think that's going
to be really huge
yeah and then you'll get if you have
like one of our nfps you get special
access to meet like all the seals behind
it here are our stories uh we got guys
that have been on like probably a
thousand missions or something and get
to hear you know these stories and then
down the road we're going to create
we're going to create video games and
different things and people can get
first person shooter training from real
Navy Seals
yeah that's killer that's gonna be so
awesome yeah yeah super exciting
um all right guys before we wrap it up
do you have any final questions
oh can I ask one please yep
um so it's for the both of you and also
thank you for having me on
um but who is the most important
influence in your life
hmm Jeff you can go first that's a
pretty good question
or influence um
I'd probably say my parents just
believing in me making me work hard from
you know the the beginning of putting me
in sports before I you know before I
knew what sports were they'd literally
put me in a put me in everything had a
pond in my backyard my aunt lived a mile
away on a farm as well
her husband passed away so they
literally built a huge gym inside this
Barn had a Pummel horse I had two ropes
that went up 50 feet to the ceiling
basketball court parallel bars
springboard all these wrestling mats
trampoline and I would just go in there
and play and play and
boards have just always been a big part
of my life and challenging myself and
never giving up at this at the same time
and or like just always supporting me
always telling me I could be whatever I
wanted to be and I think that's almost
like the biggest privilege there is
people talk about privilege and this and
that these days having parents who love
you and support you and put you into
things is the biggest privilege there is
I'd rather have the that and grow up
with with no money then then be born a
billionaire a lot of times people that
are born a billionaire and don't have
good parents they
they do not do well it's like it's like
the trust fund curse so
um yeah I'm very thankful for my parents
even with my you know dad passing when I
was young he still has huge influence
all over my life and then my my
stepfather as well coming in and
marrying my mom being an amazing father
when she had three children and uh being
like another father for me so I was very
I was very lucky
hmm
yeah I would agree I'd say my mom has
had the the biggest impact on my life as
um you know I'm sure you guys all know
the the base mom she's done a great job
with raising me with yeah with normal
values compared to the lunacy that's
going on in the media today and she's
always had um such immense belief in me
with whatever I was doing even when I
was trying to become like a professional
fortnite player a few years ago she was
um you know she was fully supportive of
it and then once I got into my business
ventures and whatnot she was fully
supportive of that so I'm forever
grateful for that from my mother and
she's a big reason I am the way I am
today
foreign
that's incredible
thank you Kevin you have no question
yeah this was for sunny
you know for this whole um gdsu stuff
do you do you have any websites or are
you working on websites for it yeah I
have a website in development right now
all right cool because I was just going
to ask you if you didn't have one
working I could help you with that
because I do create websites but if you
still need that you could um you mean
the DM
awesome bro thank you
no problem
all right I think we can wrap it up here
that was a great call Jeff thank you so
much for coming on
absolutely Sunny always uh always a
pleasure with you man looking forward to
the day you moved down to Miami and
stuff will be able to hang a lot hell
yeah I can't wait
um sneaka was supposed to join this call
I think you got held up with some other
stuff but I'll get you connected with
him too he's a massive influencer in the
in the whole Space right now so it'd be
great to get you guys to know each other
um
for those of you watching on YouTube I'm
Gonna Leave the descriptions to the
Discord and all of Jeff's business
ventures the Frogman challenge coin
everything
um so make sure you guys go check that
out he's a great guy and his businesses
are amazing so
Jeff thank you so much for coming on man
it means a lot
yeah my pleasure thanks everybody for uh
staying staying on and listening and
being interested and everything and I
appreciate all the great thoughtful
questions that you guys had too so have
a great have a great night all right
talk soon
as you think you [ __ ] cracking the
first side I'd rather riding on the wall
won't last long yeah